bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
une journée sans voitures mais pas
partout pas pour tout le monde les
expériences organisées dans plusieurs
dizaines de villes françaises ont donné
satisfaction nous verrons dans le détail
et puis réaction directe du ministre en
sports monsieur jean claude gayssot
notre invité présentation du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale martine aubry se fixe
l'équilibré des comptes l'année
prochaine médicaments génériques et
maîtrise des dépenses pour y arriver
nouvelle menace terroriste en corse un
groupe clandestin lance un ultimatum à
l'état français et annonce de nouvelles
actions violentes
la mort brutale de la triple championne
olympique américaine d'athlétisme une
florence griffith joyner s'accompagne
d'un claude de rumeurs sur le dopage
un mardi décrété sans voiture et un
mardi sans problème de circulation
globalement l'opération lancée par la
ministre de l'environnement fut
satisfaisante ça roulait plutôt mieux
dans les centres-villes même si certains
avaient devancé lors de leurs trajets
des petits malins pour éviter les zones
réservées aux piétons go de 35 villes au
moins ont accepté participé à cette
opération en voici quelques-unes depuis
paris jusqu'à grenoble et rouen
à noter que dans ces deux villes des
mouvements de grève ont perturbé la
journée faute aussi citer l'opération
anti poids lourds au mont blanc une
faible mobilisation à marseille et de
nombreuses discussions parmi les
habitants de besançon belfort nancy ou
encore nevers sur l'utilité d'une telle
journée près de paris à montreuil en
seine saint denis tout le centre-ville
était interdit aux automobiles premier
exemple avec le reportage de valérie
gaget et bernard puissesseau
inutile d'essayer à montreuil depuis 7h
ce matin si on pollue on passe plus
rendues aux piétons et aux cyclistes
le centre ville par est désert on
entendrait presque nous voler
ici l'opération n'est pas que symbolique
250 hectares sont interdits aux voitures
le plus grand périmètre parmi les 35 10
française qui participe à l'opération
la municipalité a investi plus de 300
mille francs pour proposer des
transports de substitution bus vélo ou
voitures électriques
et ça a marché beaucoup d'habitants
semblaient redécouvrir leur cité
j'avais voulu gâter je dois me faire
part et gratuit ça fait comme miser de
l'argent et en même temps c'est beaucoup
mieux on pourra respirer bien sur
comment la campagne c'est plus calme et
ça permet aux gens l'occasion même de
faire des rondes pour ses policiers
municipaux c'était aussi une première
à partir d'aujourd'hui 11 dt 6 vont
sillonner la ville
la vanne d'âge par rapport à être à pied
parce que nous sommes il est aussi avant
tout c'est de couvrir plus de terrain
c'est du côté des commerçants que les
réticences ont été les plus fortes
beaucoup n'ont pu être livrées et bien
que six parkings étaient aménagés en
périphérie avec navettes gratuites pour
le centre ville
certains ont du mal à lâcher le volant
et je lis du papier fil des produits
finis c'est un outil troy
c'est pas un outil pollution
le gène pour moi toute la journée on a
mesuré le bruit et surtout la pollution
en centre ville
elle aurait diminué de 30% par rapport à
hier la ville souhaite ne pas en rester
là
pour nous c'est un moment dans une
politique ce soir nous allons mettre le
premier coup de pioche une piste
cyclable
nous allons développer notre programme
de liaison entre nos trois parcs urbains
liaison pour les piétons et les vélos et
nous allons commencer le chantier d'un
abri pour les vélos qui sera gardienné
pour que les gens pu cesser leur vélo et
prendre le métro
montreuil renouvellera certainement
l'expérience l'an prochain le succès de
cette première journée les encourage à
faire un pas de plus alors la baisse de
la circulation s'est accompagnée d'une
baisse de la pollution c'est évidemment
l'un des but recherché dans certaines
villes des habitudes sont prises depuis
longtemps ainsi mon site la rochelle ou
encore strasbourg
les strasbourgeois ont depuis
l'installation du tramway modifier leur
comportement lors de leurs déplacements
aujourd'hui c'était donc pas une
révolution mais il y avait cependant des
petits mieux
reportage jérôme soûlard pas tricheurs
pas besoin de permis de conduire
aujourd'hui à strasbourg un simple
ticket à 10 francs suffisait pour ouvrir
toutes les portes des bus et tramways et
même d'autres moyens moins
conventionnels comme la voiture
électrique assez rigolo de silencieux
les trois peut-être est-ce économique on
n'en sait rien on va regarder mais nous
centre ville sans voiture dans la
capitale européenne ce n'est pas
vraiment nouveau
en 1991 on est passé de ceux-ci voiture
pollution bouchons et vacarme
pour arriver à cela
c'est sûr on respire mieux au centre
ville de strasbourg on est passé à
environ 55 % des déplacements
l'ensemble des déplacements qui sont
faits par l'automobile alors qu'on était
à plus de 70 % précédemment donc il ya
là à l'évidence ne serait ce que par le
développement des zones piétonnes des
résultats très très sensible la réussite
d'abord des parkings relais construit à
chaque entrée de la vide 15 francs la
journée la voiture est gardée aujourd
hui seul m et pour le même prix des
tickets de tram ou et aller retour
permet d'aller travailler en ville sans
aucun embouteillage
c'est rare à 88 trouvez que c'est comme
être prêts s'est pas déclarée il ya la
climatisation seulement
il fait chaud c'est trafic
mais dans le coeur des strasbourgeois la
petite reine prend beaucoup de place 300
km de pistes cyclables aménagées 500 km
prévus pour l'an 2000 une raison
supplémentaire pour oublier
définitivement la voiture sauf
évidemment pour les accros de l'auto
décidément irrécupérable
il faudrait encore citer beaucoup
d'autres villes ce matin à argenteuil
dans le val d'oise madame dominique
voynet estimé que ce n'était pas une
journée alibi mais une journée destinée
à réfléchir sur nos habitudes
plusieurs grandes villes ne se sont pas
associés à l'opération ainsi lille et
lyon il est vrai que de nombreuses
tentatives par le passé parfois
contradictoires ont été menées pour
concilier l'automobile et la ville avec
des échecs car tout le monde a de bonnes
raisons avancées pour préserver son
statut d'automobilistes exemple à paris
avec l'anc est de benoît mousset et
didier renquet le boulevard saint
germain hier le même boulevard cet
après-midi rendue aux piétons ou presque
pas question de faire le procès des
automobilistes mais quand même plus d'un
déplacement sur deux en voiture et en
ville se fait pour moins de 3 kilomètres
robert lui ne gagnent jamais longtemps
sa 205 il fait tout ou presque avec elle
parce que c'est plus pratique comme ça
j'ai jamais trouvé avec tout autre moyen
et en particulier avec les moyens
de transport en commun la rapidité le
confort la tranquillité et la
possibilité d'avoir en plus mon poste
qui ont des livres musique que je
choisis robert n'est pas le seul dans
son cas on compte aujourd'hui davantage
de véhicules peu de ménage 26 millions
de voitures pour 22 millions de foyers
un chiffre en constante progression
depuis 15 ans
un vol de voiture par ménage c'est le
résultat d'une longue évolution quand
même évolution qui se ralentit
progressivement et qui s'explique dans
les derniers dix quinze ans surtout par
le développement de la seconde voiture
autre problème les transports en commun
reliant paris à sa banlieue pas
suffisamment attractif est trop
difficile d'accès c'est pourtant là
qu'ont lieu la majorité des déplacements
le problème essentiel pour les
transports publics c'est que dans paris
intra muros l'offre est adapté on peut
améliorer la qualité de service
mais malheureusement pour les
déplacements banlieue à banlieue
l'offre de transports publics est
complètement inadapté ce qui pousse les
gens car ils n'ont pas d'autre solution
à utiliser leur voiture
et malheureusement après la ville s'est
adapté à la voiture et la voiture ne
s'est pas adapté à la ville après s'être
donnée complètement la voiture la ville
tente aujourd'hui de ménager une petite
place à ceux qui préfèrent une autre
conduite
voilà pour la france là nous vous
proposons maintenant une comparaison
avec un pays proche la norvège oslo la
capitale est forte de six cent mille
habitants
selon connaissait un embouteillage quasi
permanent il y a dix ans les autorités
d'oslo ont décidé de bannir l'automobile
du centre-ville il s'agissait de
décourager les automobilistes
résultat plus de voitures ou presque
puisque même les policiers ont choisi
une autre monture reportage album
nicosie et pierre laurent constants il y
à bien longtemps qu à oslo même la
police a renoncé à la voiture
chaque matin sur les quais du fjord
plusieurs dizaines de bateaux bus
desservent les quartiers excentrés et
chaque après midi
tout ce petit monde converge vers les
commerces du centre ville
voici cinq ans que la ville a fait le
choix de chasser les autos ou plutôt de
les enterrer une vingtaine de tunnels
ont été percés il les accueille tout le
trafic de transit voiture et surtout
camion évite ainsi les embouteillages
légendaires
il y a dix ans justement les affaires a
protesté parce qu'il perd des mains
quelquefois 2 milliards de courant tous
les ans à cause des embouteillages du
cos pour boston basque en norvège si
vous venez de l'ouest où d'ailleurs il
vous faut de toute façon traversier oslo
à la surface l'entrée de la ville est
réglementée 10 francs le passage ou un
abonnement 2500 francs par an national
départemental toutes les voies d'accès
sont payantes et ça change tout
moi je pense que c'est devenu très s'est
passé
très rarement de queue pour entrer ou
sortir de la ville voir moi
personnellement ça me convient bien pour
achever de décourager les automobilistes
les places de parc où sont rares entre 3
et 4000 dans le centre et cher 15 francs
par heure en moyenne
c'est les gens qui habitent ici je ne
pense pas que ce soit si bien parce que
c'est trop cher quand tu as une voiture
tu veuilles un maximum le break
oui moi j'ai un vélo c'est quand même
beaucoup plus pratique en ville par
petites touches
oslo s'est ainsi forgé une image verte
calme et tranquille mais une enquête
récente indique qu'un habitant sur deux
seulement approuvent cette politique
monsieur jean claude gayssot bonsoir n'y
at il pas une sorte de paradoxe a
organisé une journée sans voiture alors
que nous continuons à encourager la
production automobile on disait tout à
l'heure 26 millions de véhicules en ce
moment franceschi a pas un paradoxe
vouloir les deux choses en même temps
c'est à dire que la voiture est vraiment
utile
on ne peut pas y compris dans toutes nos
initiatives pour le développement des
transports collectifs diaboliser la
voiture voiture les françaises et les
français les citoyens là veulent la
chouette cela on arrive à pas tous là
tout ce n'est pas tout c'est vrai il y a
des gens qui pensent pouvoir s'en passer
ils le font c'est leur droit mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que l'automobiliste
lui même aujourd'hui est handicapé par
la situation qui s'est créée au fil des
années on a ça vient d'être dit dans
votre reportage
on a adapté la ville à la voiture le
résultat c'est qu'il y à des
embouteillages monstres il y à la
pollution il y à des millions d'heures
de perdus le stress les gâchis
considérable
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça mais
messieurs descente messieurs question au
fond quand on est ministre en sport on
est sous le joug de lobby qui produisent
des voitures des poids lourds ou autre
et donc les propos goûter que vous tenez
ce soir tout le monde les a tenus mais
on n'a pas vraiment inverser la tendance
oui en tout cas pour ce qui est du
gouvernement et de mon action dans ce
gouvernement pour les transports
collectifs cela fera deux budget
consécutif où l'effort gouvernemental
progresse de + 2 1 % en deux ans pour
les transports collectifs pour ce qui
est du ferroviaire
l'effort je vous assure et est réel pour
transférer une partie des trafics
routiers sur le rail mais je vais même
vous dire quelque chose qui est tout à
fait nouveau tellement les comportements
et les mentalités peuvent changer je
crois que la journée aujourd'hui sans
voiture est un élément qui participent à
cela j'ai rencontré récemment des
constructeurs français et étrangers et
ce sont eux qui disent qu'ils sont prêts
à aider les villes les pouvoirs publics
pour aider à ce que il
et disons une complémentarité d'aviron
se servent de la voiture là où elle est
indispensable où on en a besoin on fait
un parking de rabattement et puis on
prend le transport collectif
encore faut-il qu'ils existent et il en
manque une âme en main notamment dans
les périphéries des villes de banlieue à
banlieue tout le monde le reconnaît
alors que c'est là que les liens se
développe il ya surtout monsieur guy sur
le fait que c'est souvent très cher et
que beaucoup de personnes qui ont à se
déplacer longtemps ou pour des petits
emplois mal payés trouve que c'est très
cher les prix des transports en commun
mais vous avez raison il faut que le
tracé nord collective soit accessible
qu'il soit attractif et pour être
attractif et accessible il faut non
seulement le confort la régularité la
sécurité c'est important et il faut
aussi que les prix soient telles que on
est en vie et on puisse le prendre ça
avec en région parisienne nous avons mis
en place le chèque mobilité pour ceux
qui sont le plus en difficulté cent
soixante dix mille familles vont en
bénéficier en bénéficient cela va faire
deux millions de titres de transport
gratuit qui ont été donnés comme ça on
vient d'établir avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et avec le conseil
régional
le tarif jeune je vous assure ça c'est
les jeunes jouer un jour ça le rayon des
bonnes nouvelles alors ça réduit de
pratiquement 40% le prix des transports
collectifs sur la région parisienne et
de plus on pourra utiliser sa carte lors
des jours fériés et des week-ends pour
aller dans toutes les zones pour le même
prix en région parisienne venir la voir
son ami aller faire du sport en
aquarelle alors ça c'est là que ça c'est
formidable mais alors que ce soit
regardez bien monsieur le ministre que
ce soit les bus les métros rien ne
semble fait en revanche pour faciliter
la vie quotidienne des personnes
handicapées dans leur transport nous
avons suivi pour l'exemple un homme qui
entend bien ne pas rester bloqué chez
lui et qui veut comme toute personne
valide se déplacer librement
c'est à paris et c'est un parcours
d'obstacles édifiant reportage d'alain
doublé ce qui est jean-jacques le garrec
jean-michel paraplégique habite la
banlieue parisienne tous les jours il
prend le rer
coup de chance près de chez lui il ya
une station toute neuve bien équipé pour
les handicapés pour entrer il suffit
d'appeler et pourtant la tante va
commencer il ne peut pas utiliser les
mêmes portillon que les usagers valide
merci au bout de dix minutes d'attentes
il est dans le héros est normalement la
station d'arrivée prévenu un agent ratp
doit l'attendre il n'y a personne
alors il se débrouille maintenant il va
falloir sortir
heureusement jean michel est un habitué
il connaît les recoins réservées aux
handicapés
normalement son trajet peut être fait en
trois quarts d'heure
parce que j'attends quelqu'un parce que
bakou m pour monter dans l'avion vers je
peux pas faire ça tout seul pendant
aussi
jean-michel devra encore attendre
plusieurs fois et plusieurs fois
emprunté des passages réservés
on devra l'ouvrir spécialement chaque
étape
c'est encore une attente dans des
conditions souvent sommaires alors
regagné la surface tentait l'autobus ou
le métro suivons le
pour sûr paris sa trente sept lignes de
bus de accessible
elle ils vendent à une 91 alors voilà je
veux montrer le bus je manque
l'accessibilité du métro d'ailleurs
qu'il ne l'est pas du tout quoi c'est
aussi simple que ça
chaque jour jean-michel accompli un
exploit mais il a de la chance est un
sportif champion de basket ce n'est pas
le cas de tout le monde mais c'est
gayssot vous prenez ce tgv temps en
temps il y a une place pour personnes
handicapées par rame vous prenez le
métro c'est hyper compliqué pour ne pas
dire impossible il ya 5 millions de
personnes handicapées qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour éviter ce genre de
situations assez lamentable il s'agit
d'un problème majeur et je suis décidée
là aussi à le traiter à le traiter pour
apporter des réponses
j'ai décidé de lancer justement une
mission dès ce mois ci pour faire le
point exact de la situation parce que la
situation est elle est souvent la
suivante dans les équipements nouveaux
disons il est prévu pour l'accessibilité
pour les handicapés handicapés ça peut
être aussi des handicapés physiques ne
ça peut être aussi les personnes âgées
ou des femmes avec des plaies difficiles
noms des personnes qui se déplacent
difficilement et alors on se rend compte
que une grande partie à des équipements
n'a pas été conçu pour eux il faut là
encore il songe retard un bien gros
retard mais nous avons reçu hier
l'association des paralysés la
différence dans le cadre de leur journée
d'action la pf
j'ai discuté de cette question avant
l'été avec le co litra nous voulons
avancer il y as 400 millions dans le
contrat de plan qui sont prévus pour
avancer évolué de telle sorte que toutes
les personnes sans exception puissent
avoir accès au transport collectif et je
le même vous dire je pense qu'il faut
que nous soyons plus sévère et plus
rigoureux par rapport aux places de
stationnement qui sont prévues pour les
handicapés quand elles ne sont occupées
par d'autres je suis pour qu'il y ait la
plus grande rigueur
merci monsieur bissau dont tact on n'ira
vérifier merci bonne journée une
présentation aussi aujourd'hui de
l'avant projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 1999 par madame
martine aubry pour la première fois
depuis près de quinze ans les experts de
la commission des comptes de la sécurité
sociale prévoit un équilibre financier
pour l'année prochaine et cela si la
croissance est de 2 7%
à noter que le fonds monétaire
international vient de donner raison aux
prévisions dominique strauss kahn le fmi
prévoit en effet 2 8% de croissance
pour la france en 99 si donc cette
croissance se confirme les comptes de la
sécu sortirait du rouge
explication des projets de loi avec eric
mézil philippe jusqu'à 13 milliards de
francs de déficit pour la sécurité
sociale
c'est l'objectif que s'était fixé
martine aubry pour 1998 un objectif
réaliser grâce à la croissance même si
les dépenses de santé se sont emballées
4% de hausse
au lieu des deux ennemis attendu mais
martine aubry veut plus alors en effet
promis un retour à l'équilibré du budget
de la sécurité sociale des 99 pour
l'atteindre
la ministre des affaires sociales a
annoncé plusieurs mesures dès le 1er
janvier les pharmaciens pourront
substituer aux médicaments de marque des
médicaments génériques 40% moins chers
et tout aussi efficace
un nouveau système de sanction
collective sera mise en place pour
inciter les médecins à limiter leurs
prescriptions
une mesure qui n'est pas sans rappeler
le plan juppé et que rejette la
profession je dois constater qu'il ya
une continuité mais une comptine et qui
est à mon avis très dangereuse pour les
français parce que cette logique qui a
montré qu'elle allait à l'échec
continuera à aller à l'échec parce que
même cause même effet et après l'échec
il y à l'explosion du système chacun
sait qu'après leur martine aubry préfère
elle parlait d' évolution des pratiques
médicales afin de mieux soigner et à un
meilleur coût c'est seulement si ces
mesures lourdes structurelles qui change
de système de soins qui vise à ce que
chacun soit mieux prise en charge mieux
soigner mais aussi qu'il y ait pas de
double emploi qu'il y ait une
prescription qui soit donnée la longueur
de l'ordonance n'a jamais fait la
qualité des soins
c'est à partir de tout cela que nous
rétablirons des comptes tout en soignant
mieux
la ministre espère encore convaincre les
médecins du bien fondé de sa réforme
les prochaines réunions de concertation
s'annonce tendu
oui pour l'instant les radiologues sont
toujours mécontents de la baisse imposée
par le gouvernement pour leurs tarifs et
dans plusieurs départements dont la
loire les radiologues étaient en grève
aujourd'hui l'une des solutions donc et
rythmé il rappelait pour réduire les
dépenses de santé consiste à développer
les médicaments génériques à partir
d'une même molécule pour un même
traitement on peut prescrire des
médicaments dits génériques nettement
moins cher les pharmaciens français
pourront dès l'année prochaine
substituer à un autre produit prescrit
par un médecin sur une ordonnance à
médicaments génériques moins onéreux
c'est une pratique qui existe depuis
1993 en allemagne avec efficacité
reportage sébastien guibert et alain
poirier ces petites feuilles rose ce
sont les ordonnances des patients
allemands michael weiss pharmacien est
tenu de livrer exactement les
médicaments qui sont prescrits par le
médecin en général des génériques d'une
marque bien précises seule exception
pendant ses heures de garde ou bien si
ces stocks sont épuisés
michael weiss peut alors substituer
d'autres médicaments similaires
originaux ou génériques
je peux seulement
téléphoner au médecin si je n'ai pas le
produit même qu'il a prescrit et le
demander est ce que je peut substituer
c'est d'accord tu n'y a pas de problème
sinon je suis obligée soit de rentrer
l'ordonance soin de demander les clients
est ce que la ville a changé est revenu
plus tard droit de substitution strictes
destinées surtout à favoriser les
médicaments génériques moins chers des
médicaments que les médecins allemands
préfèrent prescrire pour éviter une
amende en cas de dépassement de leur
budget de prescription fixé à l'avant ce
modèle allemand qui s'appliquera bientôt
de l'autre côté de la frontière les
pharmaciens français pourront eux aussi
si le médecin l'autorisé substituer des
médicaments génériques à condition qu'il
n'y perdent pas d'argent
certains comme al habash souhaite garder
intégralement leurs marges
c'est un des aspects qui me paraît tout
à fait intéressant et qui pourrait
éventuellement inciter le pharmacien à
délivrer le produit générique plutôt que
l'autre à partir du moment où il va
gagner la même chose il ya simplement la
couleur des boîtes qui va changer chez
le pharmacien
et puis on va gagner une cinquantaine de
francs sur le prix de votre père le dr
bronner lui est déjà convaincu de
l'efficacité des génériques et de la
substitution
il vient d'ailleurs de s'équiper d'un
logiciel qui indique les médicaments les
moins chères économies prévues 8 à 12 %
sur le coût de ces ordonnances
ça ne change rien à la santé les gens et
ça aurait permis déjà de faire des
économies considérables dans les années
passées beaucoup de médecins et de
pharmaciens se disent donc prêts à
adopter ce qu'il considère comme une
indispensable modernisation quant aux
retraites et cela figure toujours dans
l'avant projet de financement de la
sécurité sociale
elles seront revalorisées de 1 2% au 1er
janvier prochain
et puis surtout le gouvernement mettra
en place un fonds de réserve de 2
milliards de francs pour compléter les
ressources des régimes de retraites à
venir
ce sont des mesures en trompe l'oeil a
estimé monsieur douste-blazy président
du groupe udf à l'assemblée nationale le
gouvernement souhaite ainsi préserver le
système actuel de retraite avant une
réforme le prévue pour l'été prochain
explication pascal golomer les retraites
c'est d'abord un problème d'arithmétique
en 1960 on comptait près de 5
tiff pour un retraité c'est une
estimation en 90 un peu plus de deux
actifs pour un retraité
et la tendance devrait se poursuivre
dans les années qui viennent
tout simplement parce que la population
vieillit pour que demain les retraités
conserve les niveaux de pensions
d'aujourd'hui
il faudrait donc augmenté sur les
feuilles de paye les cotisations et de
façon considérable car actuellement avec
le système de répartition c'est le
travail des uns qui financent via les
cotisations aux caisses de retraite les
pensions des autres certains préconisent
d'y ajouter un système de capitalisation
les fameux fonds de pension anglo saxons
dans ce cas chacun constitue sa propre
épargne en vue de sa propre retraite sa
pension dépendra de ce qu'il aura pu
voulu lui-même versé durant sa carrière
le gouvernement n'a pas encore donné son
avis sur la question
en attendant il met en place un fonds de
réserve un fonds destiné à alimenter les
caisses de retraite lorsque les recettes
les cotisations viendront à manquer à
partir de 2005 il faut faire des
réserves un peu comme les écureuils mais
des noisettes de côté pour cette période
nous avons le temps d'ici là de le faire
il faut qu'au bout du compte une somme
d'argent importante et à nice le côté et
il faut que régulièrement chapitre est
possible on alimente ce fonds va pour
commencer voulait créer un fonds
alimenté avec quel argent le projet
manque encore de précision
l'essentiel étant pour le gouvernement
d'afficher dès aujourd'hui son souci de
préserver les retraites par répartition
en corse
sept mois après l'assassinât du préfet
claude erignac une organisation
clandestine menaces de nouvelles actions
l'état français un texte plusieurs
feuillette est adressé à la station de
radio france rcfm radio corse frequenza
mora pour exiger des signes du
gouvernement commentaires agnès
vahramian
le texte fait six pages il n'est pas
signé mais les policiers l'ont
authentifiée il proviendrait bien d
assassin présumé du préfet erignac
en bas du document les auteurs donnent
d'ailleurs le numéro de l'une des armes
volées lors de l'attaqué de la caserne
de pietrosella en septembre 97 l'autre
pistolet dérobé lui aussi aux gendarmes
avait été retrouvé près du corps du prêt
fait mais c'est là en guise de signature
dans leur nouveau texte les clandestins
explique que l'action hautement
politique contre le préfet a permis de
faire tomber définitivement les masques
nous sommes donc plus déterminé que
jamais écrit style engagé de nouvelles
actions si dans les délais les plus
brefs
l'état colonial ne renvoie pas des
signes forts la menace est claire et
dans ce texte la référence au monde
rural constante
il faut dire que l' enquête du juge
bruguière se focalise toujours sur la
branche agricole du mouvement national
dans ce milieu des dizaines
d'interpellations ont eu lieu en sept
mois
elles permettent l'accumulation de
renseignements mais pas encore de
trouver des coupables
les clandestins et c'est plus nouveau
parle aussi de la corruption de la
classe politique demande aux élus corses
de prendre dans les semaines à venir
leurs responsabilités sur ville
aujourd'hui ni les élus ni le préfet ont
souhaité réagir et libération sous
contrôle judiciaire de jean michel rossi
l'ancien rédacteur en chef du ris bon
bout l'hebdomadaire nationalisme sur
rossi a démissionné da consulta il ya
quelques jours
perquisition au pluriel toute cette
journée aussi à social de la nef la
mutuelle nationale des étudiants de
france à gentilly dans le val de marne
ainsi dans ses filiales puis un nouveau
rapport provisoire la cour des comptes
sur la mnef relève des anomalies de
gestion mais ne confirment pas les
soupçons de détournement de fonds
hier soir le maire d'angers monsieur
jean monnier personnalités politiques
qui est souvent exprimé son refus des
appareils politiques à présenter sa
démission monsieur jean monnier 68 ans
estime qu'il appartient à ceux qui
exercent des pouvoirs de savoir attend y
mettre fin avant de se croire
irremplaçable aux états unis au
lendemain de la diffusion du témoignage
vidéo de bill clinton devant un grand
jury du procureur kenneth starr les
citoyens américains semblent garder leur
confiance à leur président près de 60%
d'opinions favorables selon un sondage
d'une chaîne de télévision
nous avons choisi le journal usa today
qui commanditent lui aussi souvent des
sondages pour vérifier cette réaction
populaire favorable et l'attitude des
médias américains reportage de notre
correspondant à washington philippe
gassot on est obligé de constater que la
diabolisation n'a pas fonctionné la
bande vidéo qui devait montrer un
président clinton
hors de lui troubler méchant parce
qu'ils avaient intérêt à le voir
dégringoler dans les sondages n'a pas
été perçu comme ça l'opéra républicaine
sur la popularité de bill clinton n'a
pas réussi pour la conduite du pays il
passe de 59 % à 68 après diffusion
peut-il être encore un président
efficace 63% des américains le pense
dans les vidéos les américains
espéraient des étincelles il s'attendait
à quelque chose de considérable
puis à pau et feu d'artifice ils ont été
frustrés ils se sont dit en fait ça
n'est pas si mal chez les républicains
ont caché sa déception on tire les
conséquences de ce ratage les
déclarations sont moins péremptoire il
ne faut pas se précipiter pour condamner
le président il ne faut pas non plus
aller trouver pour l'absoudre ce que
nous devons faire c'est respecter la
constitution à la maison blanche on
espère aujourd'hui que la menace de
procédures de destitution a légèrement
reculé
bill clinton éprouvé après la journée
d'hier continue à démontrer qu'il tient
en main les destinées du pays
avez vous suivi ce qui s'est passé hier
pas vraiment croyez moi ou non ce n'est
pas lui le rapport ni les réponses de
mes avocats
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
de me consacrer à ce que je fais pour le
peuple américain
pour le président la journée de chiens
d'hier qui avait mal commencé ne s'est
pas trop mal terminée pour les amateurs
peut être pas les télés qui ont perdu
des millions de dollars avec la
diffusion
il reste encore des pièces inédites dans
le dossier matière à opération
médiatique
les républicains qui pensaient que la
bande vidéo du président al est
horrifiée l'amérique en sont pour leurs
frais ils ont perdu la première manche
de cette bataille médiatique mais d'ici
aux élections de novembre prochain
il y en aura bien d'autres bill clinton
qui soutiendrait le chancelier allemand
helmut kohl c'est la fin du chansonnier
qu'ils l'affirment alors que nous sommes
dans les derniers jours de campagne
électorale
en allemagne le parti social-démocrate
de monsieur gerhard schröder
conserverait une avance de 3 à 4 points
sur les chrétiens-démocrates de monsieur
paul messieurs je reviens avec la règle
qu'il était prêt à faire à
science avec les chrétiens-démocrates si
nécessaire tout devrait donc se jouer
notamment dans les länder de l'ex
allemagne de l'est nous sommes rendus à
magdebourg ou 23 % de la population
active est au chômage une population qui
ne peut que constater les ruines laissé
par l'ancien régime
reportage anne consigny djs là bas
c'était la forge
retour sur les ruines du passé
industriel de l'allemagne de l'est et
sur les ruines du passé d'ilona elle
était employée ici avec 70 mille autres
personnes
et puis le mur est tombé et l' usine a
fermé en 90 depuis elle a connu la
dépression l'alcoolisme et le chômage
sans interruption c'était mieux sens où
j'avais du travail la sécurité sociale
j'avais ce qu'il me fallait pour vivre
l'année 7
et quand je vois les ruines de lusine
comme ça ça me fait mal est-ce que c'est
comme une partie de moi qui a été cassé
cogan que voteront dimanche prochain les
laissés-pour-compte de la réunification
que voteront ilona et véronique à sa
copine elle aussi au chômage pas pour
helmut kohl en tout cas financier mais à
moi qui suis rmiste on me coupe mes
revenus alors que monsieur colle comme
son parti d'ailleurs vit dans le luxe
il devient de plus en plus gros lui fait
des cures d'amaigrissement compères avec
mes impôts
quant à véronique à elles ne votent pas
les deux amis se dispute souvent à ce
sujet mais tu peux voter à gauche à
droite
je ne veux voter ni l'un ni l'autre mais
la jeune femme n'en démord pas aucun
bulletin de vote ne lui rendre à son
travail
alors à quoi bon encore plus que
l'abstention de veronica ce qui inquiète
ilona c'est la montée de l'extrême
droite et les skinheads qui occupent la
place devant le supermarché de sa cité
les chômeurs eux aussi
moi j'ai perdu mon travail à cause des
étrangers et c'est un portugais qui m'a
remplacé
oui on dit souvent les étrangers dehors
et c'est bien vrai c'est bien à cause de
ça qu'il a perdu son boulot c'est sur
leur mécontentement que surf la dvi
union du peuple allemand extrême droite
13 % aux dernières élections régionales
de saxe-anhalt ce parti réclame
l'expulsion des étrangers alors que l'ex
allemagne de l'est ne compte que 2 %
d'immigrés mais le message est simple il
fonctionne la dbu est particulièrement
performante
là où les taux de chômage culmine et
demain nous consacrerons une large page
spéciale de cette édition aux élections
allemandes
si tu lis mes affaires de dopage la
fédération française de cyclisme ajourne
la procédure disciplinaire conduite
contre les coureurs du groupe sportif
festina les procédures judiciaires sont
en cours et la seule chose que puisse
faire la fédération française est de ne
pas sélectionner les coureurs sous le
coup de ces enquêtes
ainsi richard virenque ne devrait pas
participer au prochain championnat du
monde
la mort de l'athlète américaine florence
griffith joyner triple championne
olympique toujours titulaire du record
du monde du 100 m et du 200 m provoque
évidemment des réactions de tristesse et
d'émotion mais aussi depuis hier soir de
nombreux commentaires évoquent les
soupçons de dopage qui ont pesé sur la
carrière de cette championne
exceptionnel commentaires laurent
frédéric bollée avoir été championne
olympique et mourir brutalement à 38 ans
est ce normal
florence griffith joyner et sans doute
partie avec ses mystères mais à bien y
regarder il ya des questions entre 1984
sur cette photo et 1988 l'année de ses
triomphes à séoul
la mutation physique de l'athlète est
évidente
regardez la transformation surtout au
niveau du visage
vous voyez c'est une mâchoire qui s'est
allongé les pommettes qui sont
saillantes et là ce qu'on appelle un
côté androgènes android ça veut dire des
traits masculins
si vous regardez maintenant plus loin
vous voyez une hypertrophie donc une
augmentation de la masse musculaire qui
était absolument phénoménale et ça aussi
c'est impossible sans recours à des
produits anabolisants et un accident
vasculaire cérébral
est mort prématurée il ya eu un
changement de morphologie
pour l'instant personne n'a apporté la
preuve de la consommation de produits
dopants
s'il y avait eu des contrôles positifs
là on pourrait le dire mais là on peut
absolument pas affirmé
ces types de consommation tout
simplement la soupçonner était-elle
alors là ben johnson au féminin jamais
contrôlé positif donc où la femme la
plus rapide de l'histoire seulement
rattrapé par les rumeurs flo jo comme on
l'appelait avait en tout cas arrêter
très vite sa carrière la mise en place
des contrôles inopinés suite au dopage
de ben johnson lui a fait penser que ces
contrôles est elle est opérant ce qui
n'est pas le cas et elle pensait qu'elle
pourrait plus peut-être suivre la même
préparation
c'est donc un sentiment que j'ai si ça
se trouve il faut lui laisser le
bénéfice du doute
elles partent elle part avec son secret
un secret qui valait de l'or
une autopsie a été pratiquée aujourd'hui
sur le corps de florence griffith joyner
mais on sait toujours pas si elle est
mort d'une attaque cérébrale ou
cardiaques comme on le croit et pour le
dopage
chacun aura où on gardera sa conviction
enfin cinéma demain sortie du film de
claude miller la classe de neige un film
récompensé par le prix du jury du
dernier festival de cannes
la classe de neige raconte l'histoire
d'un petit garçon soumis à ses
obsessions venue de drames personnels
pour comprendre l'histoire même de ce
film nous avons provoqué la rencontre
entre claude miller et une thérapeute
une femme habituée à écouter les enfants
reportage au brier de l'air nathalie gay
les pelouses miller est un cinéaste
singulier qui aiment prendre des risques
et son film la classe de neige en est un
conçu comme un thriller il aborde les
thèmes sombre et dérangeant de l'inceste
et de la pédophilie
pour nous il a accepté de rencontrer
martine nisse thérapeute familial et des
coups aussi ça c'est toujours des traces
de coups les enfants prennent les feux
tu tapes comme ça chaque année elle suit
une centaine d'enfants maltraités
un chiffre en augmentation constante et
j'utilise comme le dessin comme un outil
diagnostic
c'est à dire que l'enfant est envahi par
là
le trouble subie par là notamment la
sexualité génitale adultes puisque je
traite des enfants victimes de
pédophiles aux deux parents incestueux
et il reproduit spontanément dans tous
ces dessins rendent sur un cinquième
c'est par son univers fantasmagorique
que la classe de neige nous fait
découvrir nicolas un enfant fragile qui
semble renfermer des souffrances que les
adultes ne parviennent pas à percevoir
la vie de ce gamin là est peuplé de
cauchemars de rêverie et de frayeur je
crois que si on pense très fort à
quelque chose suspensions des freins
j'avais envie de raconter d'abord une
histoire qui disent qu'ils diraient que
les enfants savent tout c'est une bombe
c'est une intuition que je partage avec
beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs mais qui
savent tout même si c'est pas avec des
mots même si c'est pas avec un savoir
disons discursif les enfants savent tous
que ce soit le bien où que ce soit le
mal silencieux toujours grave nicolas
est en marche solitaire à la dérive
il parvient pourtant à nous entraîner
dans son aventure il suffira d'un fait
divers atroce survenus dans la région où
il est en classe de neige pour nous
révéler que la réalité est plus terrible
que ses cauchemars syriens disent rsa
qui demandait à lui qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire nous les îles cas qui lui
expliquait c'est lady royal bon d'accord
ça veut rien dire vu les ruses et le
thème noir et lourdes ce film risque
d'en rebuter certains pourtant la classe
de neige est empli de cette tendresse
particulière que les enfants seuls
savent nous offrir voilà nous arrivons à
la fin de ce journal je vous rappelle
deux informations nous avons développé
d'abord la journée sans voiture plutôt
réussi dans 35 villes en france une
réaction de monsieur gayssot x n'est
qu'un début et qui fera votre facilité
l'accessibilité des transports en commun
et puis enfin le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
qu'il est prévu en 99
la météo dans quelques instants isabelle
martinet annonce des températures douces
à 20h50 french kiss un film et puis le
journal est à zéro heure qu'a vrai que
bruno roger petit point dernière édition
et juste après le cercle présenté par
philippe lefait avec notamment edgar
morin et michel houellebecq avec comme
titre de ce cercle passage à l'an 2000
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde reçoit monsieur louis
viannet de la cgt à 13h vous trouverez
carole et rachid à demain 20h bonsoir
merci